on the outskirts of China's largest
desert the taklamakan a drill weighing 2
000 tons is boring a hole into the Earth
the shaft will extend 11 000 meters
beneath the surface among the deepest in
the world China's state-owned oil
producer is behind the ambitious project
this year we've drilled 37 super deep
shafts and a 14 of them have a defer for
more than 8 000 meters the average depth
in this area is near 7100 meters the
deepest among all of China's oil fields
super deep drilling has become the main
way for us to increase production
the company says project deep Earth is
expected to be completed in just 457
days
scientists say the bullhorn will reached
the Cambrian strata of the Earth's crust
which dates back more than 500 million
years
this will open up new research areas and
provided with valuable information about
evolution of the earth China is looking
for energy resources it's the world's
second largest consumer of oil and gas
and the discovery of new oil fields will
reduce dependence on foreign suppliers
currently it Imports more than 70
percent of its oil much of it from Saudi
Arabia and sanction hit Russia the
problem is it's its consumption is huge
it's uh 15 million barrels a day uh
roughly of of what they're consuming
which is you know almost uh we're
talking about 15 of the global total
there so you know that's quite a big uh
quite a big Delta there in the amount of
crude they need to bring in versus what
they produce this borehole is the second
in the world to exceed a depth of 10
kilometers the deepest is the Cola in
Russia in comparison that project took
20 years to drill Beyond 12 000 meters
in 2016 president Xi Jinping listed deep
Earth exploration as one of the four
Focus areas for scientific research the
other three are deep sea deep space and
what the government refers to as the
deep blue or information technology for
Chinese leaders investing in these
industries is an important step towards
becoming more self-reliant tensions with
the West especially the US have shown
that it can be dangerous to depend on
other countries for essential materials
forcing it to dig deep
Katrina aldazeera Beijing